guillaume chaîne aura sa chance aux jeux
olympiques 2021 remplace en 2016 à rio
le judoka de sartrouville pourra cette
fois foulé les tatamis de la plus
prestigieuse des compétitions
une fierté à bientôt 35 ans si je dois
revenir 3,80 en arrière je me voyais
peut-être pas continuer jusque jusqu'aux
jeux olympiques mais comme je le répète
souvent on arrive à se fixer des
objectifs et ce challenge et tous les
jours donc petit à petit je me suis
rapproché de l'objectif et j'ai vraiment
commencé à y croire
le report des jeux aurait été pour
guillaume shell l'occasion de bien
travailler son judo basé sur le comics
atta
les prises de kimonos le français
s'envolera bientôt vers tokyo avec un
objectif clair l'objectif comme chacun
des artistes présentent aux jeux
olympiques j'espère pour eux c'est
d'aller décrocher l'or maintenant moi
c'est mes premiers jeux olympiques donc
c'est déjà une petite victoire en soit
maintenant j'y vais pas pour figurer non
plus guillaume l'a déjà prouvé
par le passé il est capable de battre
les meilleurs et d'aller au bout deux
bouts de pas mal de compétition donc on
verra bien le jour j en soutien à
guillaume chaîne et au judo club elle la
mairie de sartrouville votre à une
subvention de 10000 euros lors de son
prochain conseil municipal pour être
performant pour s'entraîner pour pour
entraîner les plus jeunes
voilà il ya besoin d'eux
on a besoin de matériel on a besoin de
partir en stage
voilà tout ça c'est un coup on a donc on
a besoin de moyens avec un grand plaisir
qu'on accepte l'aide de la mairie et et
j'espère que voilà ça ça contre il
contribuera à beaucoup de belles choses
pour le club
guillaume chaîne est en contrat pendant
encore un an qu'au judo de sartrouville
il n'exclut pas une prolongation au club
aujourd'hui classé parmi les 10
meilleurs de france